bonjour et bienvenue sur fréquence des
vandales aujourd'hui nous recevons une
nouvelle invitée aussi d'une femme c'est
une réalisatrice de cinéma qui vient de
sortir un magnifique film sur les échecs
le tournoi c'est elodie navarre salué
l'audit bonjour alors elodie damien vous
êtes cinéaste
on peut expliquer à nos auditeurs
comment on devient si les uns c'est quoi
votre parcours
en fait c'est pas vraiment de ya pas
vraiment de chemin tout tracé moi je
suis autodidacte
j'avais jamais fait court métrage avant
est en fait à la base j'étais
journaliste je suis devenu scénariste
terry et puis j'ai rencontré des joueurs
d'échecs par hasard
et j'ai décidé de faire mon premier
projet taxi mail sur eux et ça a été le
tournoi que j'ai ensuite réalisé mais
j'avais jamais rien réalisé avant j'ai
pas fait d'école de cinéma
voilà j'ai appris sur le tas d'accord
peut-être reviendra a pris sur comment
on fait un film parce que c'est toujours
mystérieux pour ceux qui n'ont jamais vu
ça
mais au moins
forcément ce qui nous intéresse surtout
quand c'est que mona
le déchet est alors celle qui vous
intéressent par rapport à ce film qui
est fascinant ce jeu d'échecs avec de
magnifiques cima jeu
comment j'ai fortement appréciée c'est
comment vous avez découvert le jeu
d'échecs roman commence à s'y fait cette
découverte quand vous êtes entré
finalement dans ce milieu
du jeu d'échecs si vous êtes allé même
jusqu'à faire des tournois accompagné
des grands maîtres coin s'est déroulée
cette découverte
maintenant il s'est passé moi j'ai
rencontré par hasard
par hasard deux joueurs d'échecs en fait
dans le cadre de la vie privée et
et quand j'ai vu que c'était c'est un
métier joueur d'échec j'ai été
complètement fasciné parce que moi je
savais pas bougé un pion et j'étais
voilà j'avais j'avais absolument aucune
idée de ce qu'est ce nomme et j'étais
assez intrigué parce que parce que déjà
par leur intelligence par le fait de
pouvoir jouer l aveugle en simultanée
contre dix personnes avec un bandeau sur
les yeux quand il ya un côté un peu
surnaturel pourquoi né pas les échecs on
se demande un peu comment c'est possible
physiquement et intellectuellement et
et puis leur mode de vie à côté
complètement déglingué voilà côté vidéo
pâte car départ et tout le temps et
c'est en face aux contres est en fait
entre
entre leurs performances hallucinantes
sur un des chéquiers et
et la vie de gamin a fait quasiment
qu'ils avaient un côté tac patron pas
doré
aucune contrainte si ce n'est celle de
jouer donc voilà j'ai vraiment eu envie
de j'ai en fait j'ai vu un territoire
cinématographique inexplorés d'une part
et d'autre part j'ai assez envie de
faire partie de cette tribu parce que ça
m'attirait et que c'est un mode de vie
qui me plaisait donc j'ai décidé de
joindre l'utile à l'agréable
dans votre tombe donc sous riccio le
joueur d'échec quand même qu'ils sont
spécialement en plus ouvert très joueurs
dans leur comportement à bercy je les ai
choisis pour saccager le tollé si on n'a
pas du tout la prétention de parler de
tous les joueurs d'échecs mais une
certaine partie des joueurs qui sont
effectivement des vidéos pas super
branché jeu donc donc ça c'était mon
choix en tant que réalisatrice il était
aussi d'aborder le film et ce monde-là
cet angle là d'accord c'est tout à fait
intéressant ces six joueurs des années
2000 quand découvert le poker qui ont
découvert le jeu en ligne aussi qui se
sont généralisés leur pratique du feu
du jeu d'échecs notamment notre jeu et
alors
plus que cette découverte là vous avez
décidé de vous immerger de dents assez
important puisque vous avez joué bah oui
mais ça me paraît normal parce que quand
on écrit faucon faut écrire sur ce qu'on
connaît et après je dis pas que j'écris
sur un tueur en série jreige est réputé
des gens dans la rue mais
mais peu après c'est vrai que pour
écrire sur les échecs c'est qu'elle est
important de savoir ce qu'on ressent
quand on ne dit rien et chéquiers
pendant deux ou trois heures
c'est important de connaître voilà de
connaître tout ça c'est bizarre parce
qu'au départ vous parce que vous êtes un
peu jours des chefs de la police et non
pas du tout non moi au départ je savais
pas bouger un peu on s'est vraiment pas
rire du tout donc j'en ai fait déjà
comment six mois chez moi sur internet
pour apprendre les règles apprendre les
bases et commence à jouer un peu en lui
je me suis inscrite dans un crime
puis j'ai commencé à voile à l'est
aller dans des bars là où l'on joue un
peu
un jour imposée cheikh est après quand
j'ai rencontré fabienne miszewski
anthony vire immature cornette sébastien
basé toute cette bande là en fait ils
m'ont mimo adopté et j'ai passé un
moment avec eux en fait un grand plan
j'avais j'avais ma vie de scénariste et
puis déjà 28 moment je vais rejoignez un
tournoi je partais avec eux je regarde
un peu l'état leur chambre j'écoutais
leur expression je les voyais et
ouais je ressentais vraiment
lundi paul petit à petit espionne enfin
j'étais moche ou tel âge absorber tout
ce que je voyais en fait je rentrais un
tout petit à petit je suis rentré mon
lancement jusqu'à en faire partie
et voilà pourquoi en parler moi je
m'étais vraiment imposé de ne rien
écrire avant d'avoir fait une enquête
tels que je me sens que moi mais mes
joueuses échec excuses ne m'entendez
alors qu'au nouveau buteur ils vont se
dire que vous avez beaucoup de chance
parce que vous prévoyez des joueurs
d'échecs sont des vraies stars en france
cdd plus des plus grands joueurs
d'échecs de francs réussis du monde
parce qu'ils sont grands maîtres
internationaux il y en a pas tant ces
derniers
et donc quand vous dites vous allez
rejoindre les amis rejoindre un des
tournois vous êtes allés aussi dans des
tournois à l'étranger vous êtes allé
dans notre pays après les tournois à
l'étranger ce n'est pas des fins
générales journée dans les tournois
facile où il faisait la fête parce que
les cannois sérieux
c'est vrai j'avais pas vraiment ma place
j'ai pas été j'allais pas aux olympiades
au top 12 je ne sais quoi j'allais plus
acquis le cas ni en irlande
ou c'est un tournoi
nos biens c
il y avait plus de traite à côté
jusqu'au tournant plus festif et des
amateurs 10 dont ils pouvaient gagner le
tournoi ça ensemble forcément être
concentré à leur maximum koala sont
d'accord donc c'était quand même de
beaux voyages aussi mais en même temps
on est donc
donc ça c'est pour la découverte cette
plongée dans le milieu comme le tournoi
en 2007
juste je sais pas que j'ai pas compter
une dizaine un peu moyen de france à
rome alors ça vous donne quoi comme
impression quand je comprends vous avez
vécu cet incident émergents la
difficulté c'est un sport en fait que
j'avais pas réalisé que c'était aussi
physique c'est vraiment la grande
découverte que ça l'était c'était que
ces techniques deux heures sur un jeu
complètement crevé j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de dormir je suis né et j'ai plus
aucune énergie et quand je les vois
jouer pendant 6 7 heures
passionné pour
c'est quoi la dimension physique du jeu
qui m'avait
on peut pas te sentir quand on les
regarde de l'extérieur en fait il faut
vraiment jouer pour le voir et sentir
moi je vous fais pas ci était important
d'en parler de ça parce que ce concerne
un film sans dévoiler rien du tout
mais dans les partis qui filme le
tournoi il ya une
pour un joueur d'échecs très fort
réalisme sont centrés camps de
concentration très chic et qu'on n'a
jamais vraiment ressenti je dirais dans
les films précédents contre été le jeu
d'échecs
là on sent vraiment l'attention et la
concentration des joueurs pendant lé
préfet ce temps son cd ça reste des
images le film est beaucoup plus riche
le seul qui fait semblant de nier tout
ce qui se passe autour et ces moments là
sont extrêmement crédible que dirait on
a l'impression d'y être et de jouer un
un grand tournoi où les joueurs sont
quand même pas là pour rigoler quand il
sert devant l'échiquier
il ya aussi des passages
assez drôle est compris dans la tenue de
certains vols
très bien nous dit on va peut-être faire
une peut-être une première pause
musicale dans ce podcast dont les
auditeurs de fréquences et ronald avant
de revenir avez-vous sur sur l'histoire
de ce film et notamment comment ça se
déroule entre l'idée finalement et le
montage d'un film pour on arrive à ce
produit fini
ce canton au cinéma mais ce ne sera pas
forcément compte de tout ce que ça
représente avant donc merci
elodie a tout de suite donc sur internet
après la pause musicale pour la suite de
cette émission spéciale
grand film tant attendu la boutique
et
e
m
les
les amis
là
mais
ça
non
je connais
de retour sur fréquence diagonale avec
elodie la mère d'opel est réalisatrice
du film le tournoi dans la première
partie on a vu comment elle s'était
plongé dans le jeu d'échecs comme
jusqu'à apprendre à jouer
jouer des tournois elle même accompagnée
des grands maîtres on a vu ça
et on va voir dans cette deuxième partie
moment l'idée le montage du film dans sa
serai
réalise le film
d'abord commencer par les cris oui alors
il faut pardon il ya des d'ailleurs il
ya des réalisateurs qui réalise sans
écrire mémoire le coucher auteure
réalisatrice donc la première étape
c'est sûr si le scénario est en fait
après tout financement du film va se
monter sur le scénario une fois qu'on a
un scénario s'est il faut arriver à
convaincre un producteur de rentrée le
producteur en fait celui qui va chercher
les champions on est de trouver le bon
producteur
qui babinet ce m
recherche de financement et hiba
qui va rassembler l'argent nécessaire à
la fabrication du ça veut dire qu'avec
son scénario faire le tour des
producteurs on va voir ce que ça
intéresse est en mission que ça
l'intéresse on va essayer aussi de
choisir soi-même celui qui convient le
mieux absolument ça se passe comme ça
d'accord et alors après
quand on sait que
si on regarde cette histoire de film
ap lire quelques extraits moi j'ai vu
que ça a duré quatre ou cinq ans à la
maturation et la mise au point et cetera
une fois qu'on a trouvé
le producteur le scénario a été validée
éventuellement
je suppose un affinage aussi qui se fait
pour moi le tournage se fait mieux je
crois qu'il ya eu lieu choisi pour le
camp
pas un seul lieu non en fait on
mélanger deux hôtels en fait moi je
voulais vraiment dans l'idéal j'aurais
voulu tout tourné
bree se passe en hongrie mais pour moi
c'était plus logique en anglais après
la configuration financière a fait qu'il
fallait en temps d'une partie en france
quand même
c'était plus simple qu'on est parti en
france dont on fait les chambres les
scènes de bon sang de bois les trolls
chine tout cas quasiment tout se passe
dans un hôtel
tous les chambres et les couloirs sont
tournés aux barrières tel royal barrière
à deauville et tout le reste du film est
tourné
haug et nefta l'hôtel du dps qu'un hôtel
termes absolument incroyable avec des
décors grandioses et notamment la peste
pour le jour des faits que ça parle
parce que l'on sait que la hongrie s'est
joué aux échecs on connaît moult de
déchets la hongrie est un très très
grand pays des chaires oui des champions
exceptionnels et la population en
général c'est très vite jose sharks
aussi mais c'est s était fait pour moi
je tenais vraiment à les tourner dans un
pays de l'est
qu'ils soient anciens voix
l'ancien pays de l'ancien bloc de l'est
qui soit vraiment très très marquée par
culturellement par les échecs et ça a
joué dans canton la défigurant comme ça
en droit dans le fait qu'il connaissait
déjà le jeu c'est facile a expliqué
louis passe mais en fait j'avais fait
deux cents figurants
c'est un tournoi et c'était pas moi
impossible de pronostiquer ron qu'ils ne
sachent pas je les échecs presque ça
aurait été ingérable
de leur apprendre à bouger les pieds on
l'a vu pour sa part avec moi j'avais
exigé que tous les supports en soient
licenciés chacun d'abord sachez que je
pouvais faire autrement parce que si
j'avais quelqu'un qui savait pas jouer
ça aurait été voilà explique à 200
personnes comme on déplace les pions
comme on appuie sur la pendule et on ne
sait que c'est un gma bon
trudeau chine ce jour le jeune sorcier
ce qui explique l impression de
d'hyperréalisme qu'on a quand on voit ce
film on se dit d'aller se sont pas
moqués de nous ils voient vraiment un
vrai tournant dans les images qui
concerne le tournoi qui sont pas bien
entendre l'horaire est la seule
dimension du film parce qu'il ya tout ce
qui se passe au tout en fait j'ai
l'impression de diriger possible
avoir vécu dans ce film en fait un
double tournoi il ya un tournoi en
tournoi kendra l'extérieur des faits
alors
ce qu'on découvre aussi c'est qu'il y a
l'échiquier qui était consultant
ce film au départ ils étaient deux il y
en a eu plus que en quelque sorte parce
qu'alain qui se retrouvait même à jouer
dans le film
oui c'est vrai qu'il y avait deux
consultants qui était fabien michel ce
qui est idiot actu l'obédience
respectivement grand maître et naître
est pas bien ici par prêtèrent des rôles
voilà
un des rôles secondaires les plus
importants du chine
ayant acquis mais restait bayeux kim qui
apparaît également dans ce film comme un
clin d'oeil mais lui c'était
effectivement coach des comédiens
consultant technique compositeur des
parties
avec des moments extraordinaires sur
l'échiquier ne veut rien dévoiler parce
qu'il faut garder la surprise mais des
dmm le dès le début du film
moi j'étais fini de rire
daniel vasella dès les deux premières
minutes gt gt éclaté de rire
c'est des moments qu'il faut découvrir
dans le film on
il ya des moments extrêmement drôle et
notamment alors sagalevitch skis qu'on
se douter qu'il était déjà un peu clown
parce qu'on le connaît mais alors voir
le film puisqu'il est drôle il est il
est très impressionnant pas bien parce
que parce qu'il avait absolument aucune
expérience d'acteur il n'avait jamais
mis les pieds sur une scène il y avait
oui et il se révéler d'un talon est
ruiné
naturel absolument confondant et même
quand il fallait dans des scènes un peu
plus loin non des scènes d'émotion a
vraiment pas évidente
il a été
composé un personnage qui a été vraiment
très très très impressionnant
en ce qui démontre une bonne fois pour
toutes qu'on peut très bien grand maître
d'échecs est aussi appelée aussi les
mains parce ça c'est pas donné à tout le
monde lui l'a vraiment ce truc
exceptionnel enfin c'est un acteur n'est
en fait il y en a très peu
c'était celui chine par exemple mais
mais
mais c'est un acteur newey qui n'a pas
besoin de travailler pour est excellent
quand ils jouent donc c'est très
impressionnant
donc ça c'était pour la partie fille on
a aussi nos acteurs les acteurs phares
du fou
son
trouve excellent et qui en plus pour
préparer ce film peut aussi se sont
plongés dans la pratique du jeu et dans
toutes les situations du film on peut
dire qu'ils trichent pas et qui donne
vraiment vraiment l'impression d'être de
vrais joueurs d'échecs
ce qui là aussi était pas forcément
toujours le cas dans les films ont
traité du jeu d'échecs non mais vraiment
l'impression d'avoir des joueurs
expérimentés qui ont de texel posture
l'excellente façon à la fois quand il
joue évidemment mais aussi on joue parce
que un joueur d'échecs
il a sa façon d'être aussi on peut
reconnaître ou pas et là on s'y
reconnaît vraiment feuilles de partie à
la main
discussions techniques
on s'y croit travail de ces deux acteurs
qui font pas du tout joueur et non mais
surtout la part de michelangelo qui qui
joue au principal et
oui beaucoup plus de scènes d'échec que
nous par exemple et lui il a vraiment
fait six heures des chèques par jour
pendant pendant plusieurs mois
il est parti en tournoi il est devenu
avec des joueurs sa gestuelle était
vraiment très sûr sa gestuelle / cpo sûr
ça fait effectivement un énorme travail
de diversion quasiment même que le mien
en fait et vous appréciez les cours
d'échecs et alors on a aussi j'ai une
hauteur très pas pu voter mais notamment
j'ai noté le rôle du petit génie parce
qu'il ya un petit génie dans ce film qui
joue le rôle du but
on est tous un champion précoce
squillaci plantes gerland
qui max qui joue excellemment et au
québec extrêmement espiègle ce film tout
en ayant du talent on le boit et on a
l'impression d'avoir vraiment là aussi
mon petit génie des échecs précoces
facile et peu taquin à lui il s est un
vrai petit génie des c'est un vrai petit
génie au fait qu'est-ce qu'il est
parfois longue
il a
mercredi par les trois langues il avait
deux ans d'avancé à l'école il avait mi
temps et on a retrouvé dans un club
d'échecs et joueur d'échecs au souffle
s'en sort très bien et jusqu'au bout
vraiment on y croire
son un rôle extrêmement important ça
fait partie d'une des trams précis
pattison et la trame principale du film
le rôle que joue ce petit génie qui
viennent titiller
la mécanique des villas
on peut dire ça comme ça
voilà donc ça si pour la distribution
alors on a parlé un petit peu de ce
montage est aussi que ces deux endroits
donc deux hôtels français budapest
d'étudiants
de la crédibilité
et simple
et alors
sur le montage
duffy comment ça se passe je suppose
donc
on fait des
les rushs en film tout s'appuie sûr il
ya plusieurs reprises je crois pour les
scènes pour sûr qu'on va récupérer une
bonne prise
et et après il ya toujours une période
de montage du film on s'assure qu'on se
déroule sa cellule en avoir passé mais
c'est l'une des passes de plus longues
passes et faut sélectionner les bonnes
scènes là où les comédiens sont debout
mais vous les bons plans technique pour
les montages c'est quasiment
sap à une réécriture du scénario mais
quasiment parce que c'est ce qui va
donner le rythme c'est ce qui va donner
à ces capitales en fait comme étape
après c'est à décrire c'est pas évident
parce qu'on est dans une seule avec un
monteur et
et on discute de quels plans choisis
quel plan mais à quelle place et voilà
c'est vénération et
mais ce sera un peu mieux raconter je
conscient tout raconter mais ça dure
longtemps
facile non
on a mangé contre catane avec la
maturation de la banque sur quatre
travaillent qui en fait même peut-être
l'essentiel du film le montre
et alors après il ya aussi tout ce qui
est après faire connaître le film il ya
eu des voyages il en californie a été
présenté aux états unis ouais ouais j'ai
été fait on pas que le film a été
sélectionné au festival pourquoi los
angeles se présenter de son conseil
on a eu l'honneur de pouvoir aller
défendre le sim la barre et qui a été
très bien reçues mais c'est sélection
des états unis ce palmarès parcours en
france et il ira aussi au festival de
six acteurs en jeu l'un d'eux
les etats-unis m james en a ça marche
bien alors moi je pense qu'il ya dans ce
film il ya des moments cultivables en
histoire suffit
au delà de sa sortie parce que fait
partie des films jeux sans doute qu'ils
vont devenir
référencés
vouloir parler du jeu d'échecs dans un
film
faire mieux et ça va pas être simple je
pense qu'on est allé au dessus de la
diagonale du fou parce qu'on est au
dessus de sortie de bobby fischer qui
sont deux excellents films soit un échec
une tension dans tout le long du film
avec des moments de l'explosion de rire
détente
on n'est pas sûr de jouer une partie
dans le ville en fait si on suit ça
plusieurs fois avant d'en tirer la
quintessence de ce film là je pense
c'est ça qui fait que des filles peuvent
durer longtemps parce que vous beaucoup
pas dire est qu une seule lecture suffit
pas en tirer la quintessence
alors il ya des phrases du culte je me
suis fait miniaturisés par un foetus qui
m'a inventé ça c'est pas bien liszewski
coc bic et ses vitraux et les
expressions les plus dingues du sim
c'est lui qui les a privés d'espacés pas
la seule fois incroyable a lancé à mon
avis ça ça va faire son parcours c'est
pas près de quitter l'esprit des joueurs
il ya dans les tournois dans les comptes
rendus de grands événements etc
à mon avis ça va revenir et ça va faire
vivre ce film
dans la longueur j'ai envie de dire
aussi que le jeu d'échec parce que
vous savez des sur le jeu d'échec ce jeu
plurimillénaire
c'est très très longue histoire et qui
se construit patiemment en doucement
tranquillement
avait des gens passionnés comme vous ont
découvert la fascination qu'a su jeunes
et que contribuer comme vous finalement
à le faire vivre et à le faire durer
comme ça au delà de
au delà des vies humaines parce qu'on
est vraiment dans la très longue durée
il faut dire merci à tous les auditeurs
de frais à la place des auditeurs de
fréquenter bonal je me fais le porte
parole je vous dis merci
de la part des joueurs d'échecs présents
et à venir qui vont découvrir ce film et
qu'ils seront fiers de voir que le jeu
d'échecs
fascine au delà des joueurs qui le
pratiquent fond c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir de ce film vous êtes venus de
l'extérieur
la fascination plein les yeux et vous
l'avez retranscrit magnifiquement qui
plus est en nous appuyant sur quelques
stars de l'échiquier qui ont joué leur
rôle à fond
merci beaucoup c'est très gentil
remercier avoue surtout et merci à tous
les joueurs d'échecs qui suit m'aurait
pas existe parce que ils m'ont
accompagné de la première ligne du
scénario à
aujourd'hui la sortie donc
on a la chance grâce à eux c'est leur
fils
voilà donc le tournant que vous verrez
et forcément tôt ou tard si vous aimez
les jeux d'échecs je serai un peu obligé
d'aller le voir quand même
avec les lots de la mer c'était sûrement
diagonal je vous laisse avec mac os
générique fétiche bloquer les brise
on
non
m
et